[MUSIC]
CHET HAASE: So
we're going to talk
about what's new in Android.
If you recognize the
title of this talk,
it may be because we gave a talk
eerily similar to this before.
If you saw that
talk at Google I/O,
you may find some of
the material today
eerily similar to what
we said back in May.
That's because we gave out
a preview release that,
thankfully, was
pretty representative
of the final release of M, which
finally came out very recently.
We have added, we--
when I say we it's
the royal we, because
there's only one of me
up here-- we've added
a bit of information
to talk about stuff that has
happened since that preview
release, so I'll go over that.
In the meantime, I would like
to introduce my co-speaker.
he decided that he
couldn't join me.
He actually got
really sick the night
before he was gonna come out
here and bailed yesterday.
So originally Dan
Sandler was going
to join me for a
reprise of our talk
that we did, and then Dan bailed
on me for some pathetic excuse,
like work.
And then Romain was gonna
join me instead as a stand in,
and he was gonna
fake a Boston accent.
That didn't work either.
So now it's just me, pretending
that I don't have a problem
and that everybody
actually wants to be here,
but just couldn't.
So, I love this
post on the barbecue
site, where apparently I now
have like a Catholic four name
name.
It's Chet Haase Romain Guy.
And that's the person
who won't be joining me.
So, on with the show.
First of all, one of the
things that's new since I/O,
obviously, is some of the
new hardware that we have.
So the Nexus devices just
came out, the 5X and the 6P.
Actually, so has anybody
actually seen, held, bought
these things yet?
OK.
I'm going to claim a
majority, although I
think I saw seven hands.
Actually the availability
was a very recent, right?
You could do a pre-order.
I don't know if they're
actually delivering it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHET HAASE: 5X.
Oh, cool.
OK.
See, I'm on the inside.
I don't know the
details on the outside.
So I was going to go over
quickly some of the specs
here, some of the more
interesting stuff.
Quality camera.
We'll see some pictures later.
I'm not a good photographer,
but I was surprised.
I took a picture of a sunrise.
I thought there were sort
of some interesting reds.
And it actually came out
with a really crisp detail,
at a fairly dark
point in the morning,
so that that was sort
of my first alert
that, like, the sensor
is a lot bigger.
You can get a lot
more light in there
and do a lot more with it.
We'll talk a little bit about
fingerprint stuff that's
enabled on these devices.
USB type C. We'll mention
some of the specs here.
So, I actually prefer
the 5X just because I
like the smaller form factor.
It's a little bit
taller than the Nexus 5.
But in the meantime,
it's got faster hardware,
so it's got the,
what do they call it?
The Hexa Core.
Hexa being some
language for six,
so we have four little cores
and then two mega cores.
So fairly good performance
on the CPU side.
Upgraded GPU from the Nexus 5.
Fairly substantial
battery in there.
On the 6P side,
much larger display.
A little bit smaller
than the Nexus 6.
Which was too big for me.
This is a little bit,
little bit smaller, easier
to handle with one hand.
Again, upgraded GPU and CPU
from what we saw before,
including the Octa-Core.
So we've got four little
cores and then four big cores
when we need to run something
really substantial in there.
So on the camera, lots of
numbers, not all of which make
sense to me.
So 4k video slow motion capture.
I played with that
the other day.
Um, interesting.
Double click on-- I
don't know if anybody
has seen this feature
yet in the camera app--
if you double click
when the screen is off,
it will automatically
launch into the camera.
Or even if you're logged
into the phone, if you double
click it will go to the
camera immediately as sort
of a quick way to get into
kind of a common use case
that people had.
So you don't have to turn
the phone on and then do
the thing that you want.
Meanwhile, fairly
large resolution
pictures that come out of it.
Fairly large pixel size
and large sensor area,
so we get a lot more light
coming into the camera.
So here are some
sample pictures taken
by a much better photographer.
I asked Romain Guy.
I always find when I
want to put pictures
in a presentation of
mine, it's much easier
to just steal them from Romain,
who knows how to take pictures.
So these are some that he took
around the office and home
the other day.
Sort of demonstrate various
things including-- I
wanted to end on an American
flag, because, Texas.
Let's see.
So Nexus Imprint.
This is actually my favorite
feature about these devices.
The really cool thing is the way
I store my phone in my pocket
is usually face
down, upside down.
And as I take it
out of my pocket,
I put my finger in the fairly
cleverly placed location.
And then by the time I'm
looking at the phone,
it's actually unlocked and on.
So it's just kind of a nice
sort of quick power on thing.
It can also be used to
authenticate your applications
that you write, and we'll
go over a little bit of that
later.
I haven't used those
applications yet.
I'm not a pay user
right now, but it's
kind of huge for me just
having the unlock feature.
USB.
I find this kind of cool.
I don't know if anybody
else goes through this.
With the normal sort
of USB, what the B,
the micro USB
adapter, I always have
to go through three
efforts to plug it in.
Right?
So you try it and that didn't
fit, so it must be upside down.
And then you turned over
and you try it again.
And in fact that was wrong and
you were right the first time,
so then you turn it over
and then insert it correctly
the third time.
So USB C. Saving two
efforts on every plug-in.
Thank you very much.
OK.
Let's talk about
Android 6, Marshmallow.
Here's a picture
of the little guy
outside freezing
at, I don't know,
5:30 in the morning when
I got there that day.
First of all,
runtime permissions.
So, who's actually enabled their
app for runtime permissions
so far?
A few of you.
Good.
More would be better.
So this is something that
users, as well as developers,
have asked for a long time.
I think the trick is that it
does mean some growing pains,
right?
Because now, well A, you need
to do a little bit more work
to actually opt into
this thing, but also you
need to handle conditions
that couldn't come up
before because users may
actually deny that permission
to your application.
Or they may not want
that permission granted
and you actually need it.
So there may be a little
bit more interaction.
This requires the user to
explain why this thing is
needed so that they understand.
On the other hand,
we now no longer
have this set of
blanket permissions
that the user is faced with when
they install your application.
Why is it that your chat
application needs my camera?
Why is it that your game
needs to know where I am?
Some of these things
don't make sense
and shouldn't have been there
in the first place, frankly.
Some of these things
make perfect sense
in the context of
the application,
but it's hard to gauge
that when you're just
faced with this huge
list of permissions
when you want to download
and install the application.
So it's much more granular
and explanatory now.
So this is the traditional model
and this is still the model
that people will see
on pre-M releases.
So, I need the following things,
and then you have no choice.
You're like, well
either I'm going
to give you all
these permissions,
or I'm not going to
stall your application.
And if you want the application
you kind of got to do it.
In the new world, instead,
you ask for permission
when you need it.
When a particular
permission needs
to be granted in order for
you to perform some function
like actually using the
camera or using the location,
then you ask the user for that.
Once they've granted the
permission, you have it,
you do not have to
ask for it again.
On the other hand, the user
can deny things at any point.
You can go into settings and
look at all the permissions
that are used by
all the applications
and disable these selectively.
Which means that your
application, especially if you
wrote it pre-M and you haven't
touched the code since,
maybe denied a permission that
you thought was there because,
when it was installed,
that permission was there.
So we have a
mechanism internally
to throw an
exception or an error
when you don't
get that exception
and hopefully your code is
robust enough to handle that.
But if you're re-attacking this
with the M runtime permissions,
then you want to be able to
handle that intelligently,
and you want to also be able
to give the user a little bit
more information
when it's necessary.
I'm not sure if I
show the flow there.
Let's see.
No, let me go back.
So one of the things
that helps is, there's
sort of a Two Ask policy.
So we'll ask the user,
and if you think,
well this permission
will be granted.
There's no reason
why they wouldn't
let me have access
to the camera,
because obviously it's a
photo booth application.
So you pop up the
permission and the user
says no, I don't want this.
OK.
Well, we allow you to ask
again as the application.
But that second
time we ask, we're
going to also include
a check box that says,
never ask me again
because otherwise, it's
like you're spamming
the user every time
you ask for this thing.
But maybe before you pop
up that permission again,
you can say, OK.
We need access to
the following thing
because we have this
feature called A Camera
and this is an application
called A Photo Booth.
So maybe you actually want
to enable this permission.
And once you think
the user actually
understands why you're
asking for the permission,
then go ahead and tell us to
expose that dialogue again.
We'll pop it up.
Hopefully they do
the right thing
and you can go on
about your business.
So these permissions,
everything you're asked for.
But the user of the app
actually has to deal with it.
I went over a lot of that stuff.
We'll keep going.
There is a Compat API
now, so you can access
this in the support library.
There's a couple of resources
for more information.
First of all, there was
permissions in M session
at Google I/O. It followed
the What's New in Android
talk that we gave back in May.
That's on YouTube, so go
ahead and search for it
by that title.
And Ben [? Poise ?]
explains a lot more
of the details of how
and why this thing works.
And also we had
Ben on the podcast.
Actually, I'm curious.
How many people know about the
Android developers backstage
podcast?
Because this is like
one of those secrets
you sort of do this thing and
you ship it out to the world
and you have no idea how many
people, or who actually knows
this thing exist.
So it's a podcast that I do with
Tor Norbye from the tools team,
where we interview
mostly Google people,
not exclusively, it just
happens to be easier
to walk down the hall than it
is to email somebody externally
and organize that.
So we talk to a lot
of Android developers
basically about how stuff
works, either internally
or externally.
So we had Ben on to talk more
in depth about permissions,
so you can check out
that episode if you want
to know more of the internals
and how to actually interact
with permissions.
Voice interaction.
So we had the capability already
to have an intent launched
with a voice action.
Now there is interaction,
so you can actually
interact with the user after
they launch your intent.
So, you specify this
intent, and you say,
I am going to be launched
on Voice Actions.
And you can already say, well
if it's a voice interaction,
do the following thing.
But now you can actually
go back to the user
and get some
clarifying information.
So you can say, OK, given
the following string,
go ahead and do a
text to speech thing
and say this to the user to
get some more information.
And then when you've
got that information,
launch my confirm
implementation.
And once I've got
that, then I have
the following
clarifying information.
So basically, they
said something
that launched your
app, you respond,
asking some clarifying question,
they responded to that,
then you get that
additional information.
You can go on about
your business.
Fingerprints.
Again, my personal favorite
feature of the new devices.
With that capability,
you have the ability
to pop up your
own user interface
for fingerprint authentication.
So there's APIs, where you
can get the information
from the sensor and say,
OK, have they authenticated
that they are the correct user
with the fingerprints that
are stored on the device.
And you can have
your own UI to help
the user understand
what they're doing
and what the result of that was.
Or you can use the
standard UI by calling
createConfirmDev
iceCredentialIntent.
That's a mouthful right there,
that's a lot of characters.
I think you're going to wrap the
line just with the method name
there.
So you can have us pop
up the normal lock screen
UI to ask the user to
authenticate that way as well.
There's a couple of samples
that are good to check out there
on the d.android.com site.
The fingerprint dialogue as
well as a confirmed credential.
And there's an I/O by the
fingerprint in payments APIs.
This was a sandbox talk at
I/O and then they recorded it
as an I/O Byte, so you can
search for that title name,
and you'll find Maya
talking about this.
We also-- secret for
the people in the room
that nobody outside this room
knows until the video is posted
in an hour, is that
we've had a conversation
with some of the fingerprint
people on the podcast as well.
So hopefully that will come
out sometime soon we'll see.
Android back up.
So you can always back
up everything-- sorry not
everything-- you could
back up a bunch of stuff.
We would back up things
about your accounts
so that when you restored
onto a different device,
or installed your account
on a different device,
we would pick up some of
those, sort of, common account
settings.
You know, the WiFi routers you
could connect to, or whatever.
But now we actually back
up basically everything,
except temp and cache
directory information.
So, when you target the MSDK,
we will back up all your stuff
automatically, for free
and store it in the cloud.
And then you can opt out
of that, if you want.
So there's a simple way
of opting out, using
include and exclude
tags in an XML file.
So in your resource
directory, and XML directory,
you would create this
backup scheme dot
XML file that you refer
to in your manifest,
and then you give us
include or excludes.
By default,
everything's included.
If you'd give us an include,
or a set of includes,
then only those things
will be included.
Or if you give us excludes,
then only those things
will be excluded
from the full set.
And then additionally,
you can just
tell us to not back up anything.
If that's just not something
you want to do, that's fine.
Google Play services.
We recently released
8.1, I believe.
So back at I/O, we
talked about the thing
that I think is still
pretty critical for people
to key into, which is
GCM Network Manager.
This is the Google Play services
equivalent of job scheduler,
and in fact, when you're
running on a release that
has job scheduler as
part of the framework,
it'll use that internally.
But it's the same idea.
An API is for
basically saying, I
want to do things
when it's appropriate.
So I want to do this when
the device is plugged in,
or when I have high
bandwidth data,
or when I have WiFi,
all of these things
so that you're not constantly
syncing, or syncing at times
that are totally
inappropriate for the user
experience, or the device
capabilities or the data plan,
or whatever.
There's a bunch of
other stuff that's
been added also in Google
Play services 7.5, as well
as the releases since then.
Nearby came out over the summer.
Again, we had a chat
with those folks
on the podcast, if you want some
of the inner details of that,
sort of, close
proximity communication
between devices to set up
things, like passing tokens
back and forth to get everybody
on the game dash board,
or whatever.
Mobile Vision, the ability
to do face detection,
as well as bar code scanning.
The new permissions model.
There's some
marshmallow permissions.
APIs in the more recent
Google Play services stuff.
Maps can come up now
in ambient modes.
I don't know if people have
noticed the ambient mode
on the new devices.
It sort of comes up with
this simple and cheaper sort
of black and white screen to
give you the basic information.
Then you can go launch into the
full color screen if you want.
Player Stats app invites.
More information
on the blogs that
were posted about Google Play
services, so check those out.
So battery.
It turns out that battery
continues to be an issue ,
and probably will continue to
be an issue after this, as well.
Because basically apps
are doing more and more.
The more capabilities
that a device has,
the more apps want to
take advantage of that.
They want their
data, all the time.
Then we have a
problem on the device,
because if all the applications
are doing lots of stuff
all the time, then
pretty soon you're
going to drain the battery.
So we work really hard
at the platform level
and we encourage apps to work
hard at the application level,
as well, to reduce the
amount of drain overall.
So there were a
couple of major things
that we did in the release,
and people with M devices
will notice this, especially if
you have your device not being
used for a while, then it's
going to drain the battery far
less than you expect
it to because we've got
this thing called Doze mode.
So if it detects
if it's basically
sitting on a counter
somewhere not moving we're
using the sensors to detect
whether the device is actually
being used and if it's not
then why are we doing anything.
So we'll go into
a deep sleep mode
where we're not
sinking anything.
We will still wake up for
the important things, if you
have an alarm
scheduled or whatever,
but we're not really the--
background apps aren't
going out and getting a bunch
of data, which is frankly not
going to be used if the
user is not actually
using their device at the time.
So we've got Doze mode.
We've also got App
Standby mode, which
is more at the application
level where we will notice
that an application has not been
used for some amount of time,
several days or
whatever, then why
is that app continuing to sync.
Right?
If I haven't actually used
my reader app in four weeks,
why is it going
out and retrieving,
you know, sync
points in the books
that I'm reading on
a different device.
There's no reason for that.
So we'll notice
that, and then we'll
restrict the data usage
of that particular app
so that it's not constantly
running and syncing
in the background, draining
your battery for absolutely
no reason whatsoever.
We have Assistant
Support This is
the Now On Tap stuff
that you may have seen
at Google I/O. There's the
ability for your application
to provide more information,
more contextual information.
So there is some APIs that
you can opt in to here,
override on provide assist
data, on provide assist content,
and provide more information
back to the system
so that we can give the user
even more context for how
to use your application,
given the information that
was on the screen at the time.
Data Binding.
So this is a big thing
that we did in the UI area.
It's basically a way to save
the developer from writing
a lot of boilerplate code.
So it's not doing anything
fundamentally new,
it's just doing
it in a way where
we do the work instead of you.
So if you imagine in a
UI there is usually a lot
of listeners in the system.
You're setting up, you're
creating these setters
and getters and listeners, and
sending messages all around.
And a lot of that is done
because basically the user did
an action over here,
which needs to propagate
to another item over there.
You're dragging a
progress bar and you
want to update a
text view somewhere,
a label with the value
of that progress bar.
Or the data itself
changed, and you
want that information to be
displayed in the UI somehow.
Well, now you can actually
connect those dots
through data binding.
We'll automatically
propagate that for you.
So let's take a look at
a tiny little example.
So you may have
a simple app, you
have some image
views and text views,
that are based on
information from some data
that you're getting over
the network or off disk,
or whatever.
So we have a new kind of
layout tag called Layouts,
and inside the
Layouts tag goes all
of the information you used to
put for your view hierarchy.
So the old layout .xml file,
or that goes in the layout
resource directory, that
stuff still goes in there.
And you can see this in the
slide in the frame layout tag.
Normal view hierarchy stuff.
But, in addition
to that, we also
have a data area
of the layout where
you declare the
variables that are
going to be used by Data
Binding in the rest of the file.
So we say, well we've got
a variable named Item,
and here is the class
that it refers to,
and then we have the items
below that refer to it.
And say, well, we want
the source to be-- we
want the source of the image
to be the value of this image
field in this item.
And it will go in and create
or use the getters and setters
as necessary in there.
And then for the text view we
want the information in there
to come from the item itself.
But notice it's not just
simply grabbing a field.
We also have some
basic syntax in there
that you can use to make
an expression in there.
So here we're actually
formatting it and saying,
make a string out of
the following values
and then display that in
the text view instead.
So then we get the dollar sign,
in dollars and cents in there.
So, again, fairly
straightforward in what
it's doing, but there's
a lot of stuff going
on under the hood in particular
a lot of systems like this
could be written
using reflection.
OK, well they told us to
go look for this thing,
so then at runtime, you're
going into the class
and you're looking for
a field with his name
or a getter and
setter with this name.
But instead, we
do pre processing
So we take this
layout file and we
create the glue code,
all the classes that
are going to be doing the
monitoring for the changes
and data, and you know the
getters and setters that are
necessary, and the listeners.
We create that for you, so
that at runtime, we actually
just send the information
through the normal mechanism
that you would do if you
wrote optimal code to do this.
So it's very
straightforward, there's
no reflection used
in the system.
It's all done at build time.
Most of the
functionality is actually
in the tool in Android
Studio, and then there's
a little bit of
support in the support
library with the
class of that you
need to implement to observe
some of the information going
on.
There was a sandbox talk at
I/O which was not recorded,
but there was recently another
talk at a meet up on data
binding.
And I think we're going to
have a talk in an upcoming
conference, as well.
So there should be some
recorded talks by the folks
who work on that.
Also, we had them
again-- I don't
want to keep
plugging the podcast,
I'm just trying to
think of the resources
that we have for
this stuff-- we had
Guy and George on our recent
version of the podcast,
talking about that as well.
So some of the UI
features that we had,
in addition to data binding.
We had a whole bunch
of stuff around what
we call the Design Library.
The Design Library was
basically us saying,
well there was a whole lot
of stuff in the material spec
that we asked
developers to implement,
so that they could
have applications
that look consistent
on the platform
and we thought were good
UI practices and good UI
experiences for people to have.
And in the meantime,
you're on your own.
So, we took a step
back and said, OK.
What are some of
the common patterns
that we're telling
developers to implement,
which we could
help them out with.
So we created a bunch of
smaller classes and UI widgets
that developers can now just
use to get a consistent look
and feel with everybody else
using those same widgets.
At the top of that
hierarchy is Coordinate
a Layout, which is-- you
wouldn't use directly,
but it's basically the
Chrome that everybody plugs
into for these other pieces.
It's sort of the things
sitting at the top
if you want to have
your Snackbar you, need
to sort of plug it in at
the top of the hierarchy,
not just have it
hanging out in space.
Or if you want the FAB to sort
of live somewhere standard,
all this stuff is plugging
into the coordinator
layout, kind of the architect
of the rest of these things.
We have the Snackbar.
We have Tablayouts.
We've got the NavigationView.
Just standard UI
patterns that we've
been talking about for a
while, but we encapsulated them
into these standard widgets
in the Support Library
so that everybody can use these.
And because it's in
the Support Library,
you can use those on
releases prior to M, as well.
TextInputLayout, so it
gives you more information
about the text that's being
expected in that field.
And then the FAB.
And we always thought--
the question came up
while we were in development
in the L release about,
well, should we
release a FAB widget.
And we decided not to because,
A, it's not straightforward.
It's not like you're
gonna have a fab widget
and it's gonna do
everything you want.
Well where do you want
that fab widget to live?
Like what is the
container that it actually
lives in, since it's sort of
overriding several of them?
So that was a little
more complicated now
solved by the
Coordinator Layout thing.
But also it was like,
well, it's a circle.
It's a circle with
a drop shadow.
You know.
How hard is this thing.
Turns out it was
trickier for some people,
and in particular it
was also inconsistent.
People would pick different
elevations, or different ways
of displaying the
shadows, or they
would have circles that
were of different sizes.
So we thought, maybe it's better
if we actually just come out
with a standard widget so that
everybody has the same notion
of what a FAB is.
So there it is, the FAB.
Sorry, I should say
that you work with UX,
and they use a lot of
acronyms and buzzwords, which
if you're not in
the design group,
you have no idea what
they're talking about.
So I worked with them,
like, for several months.
And I kept hearing
them say FAB, FAB, FAB.
And then finally I just
started saying FAB.
Floating Action Button.
All right.
Everybody clear on that?
Floating Action Button.
Stop talking like a designer.
All right.
Other UI changes.
So, RecyclerView.
Swipe-to-dismiss.
There's a nice
interaction point there.
If anybody has tried to
make this work in list view,
not straight forward.
Same thing with drag & drop.
I know because we
did videos explaining
how to do this in ListView.
One of the whole goals
with RecyclerView
was to give developers and users
something out of the box that
just kind of did what you
wanted, as opposed to giving
you the framework
in the plumbing
and then you're on your own
with this fairly complex widget.
Which resulted in people
doing it in different ways,
or simply not doing it because
it was a complicated problem
to solve.
So RecyclerView came along.
It's much more
plugable and flexible,
with a lot of built in
behaviors, like animations
for the simple
straightforward operations.
And then we've been
adding things to it since.
So drag & drop and
swipe-to-dismiss
are two of those.
And then more recently
in the 23.1 release,
which came out last
week, we took another run
at item animations,
in particular.
We got the request
from some people
that it was difficult to
do a richer animation when
the content was changing.
There was a built in animation
where you could say, OK.
The following item changed.
And then we would replace
the old view with the new one
and we would do a cross
fade between them.
That's reasonable,
but if your views
are very rich and expensive,
you didn't necessarily
want to create a new
view for that thing.
Additionally you might
want a richer animation
to animate, you know, the
text into its new location,
or a color change, or whatever.
So with the new
content animations,
you have the ability to
override and do something custom
all on your own.
And in addition to that, you
can actually use the same view,
so we're not necessarily
going to replace the holder
if you don't want us to.
We can have you
reuse that holder
and you can animate the stuff
around, however you want.
In WebView, they
have the ability
to now render
offscreen, which is
helpful in the
particular situation of,
if you want to animate
something on screen
and you don't want it to
be drawing at the same time
as it's doing that.
So you can pre draw
it, using more memory
to do that off screen
and then animate it in.
Notifications.
So there was a new class added
called Icon, which is basically
a holder for several different
kinds of information.
It can be a resource ID or
a bitmap or a byte array.
This is basically about having
a more optimal way to hold
the information, so that
we're not constantly
recreating it along the fly.
If you're passing
around a notifications,
if you're passing
around a resource ID
and then it needs
to get inflated
by this part of the
system and then passed
over this other process, it
then inflates that resource ID.
Like, everybody's going
through the same work
over and over again.
So instead we have
this holder structure
that holds whatever
representations
are most optimal.
So you can create
it with a resource,
that's one of the ways
you can use this thing.
But can also create
with a bitmap.
So this could be
handy if you have
resources that
indicate information
that can be variable over time.
So, Dan's example, when we
talked about this at I/O,
was a weather application
may have different icons
for different temperatures.
Well since we only allowed
you to create notifications
from resources before,
then you would actually
have to have assets
representing all
the different possible
combinations of temperatures,
which could be a
lot if you don't
live in California or Hawaii.
And so instead, you can actually
create those dynamically.
And then you can
create this icon class
with a bitmap instead
of the resource ID.
So you don't need to have any of
these available at build time.
Instead, they can be
generated at run time
whenever you need them.
We had some changes in
text mostly in the UI area.
So the way that you select
text is much more natural
and powerful now.
So you've got the text
handles as before, but now as
you drag them out, they expand
by word, instead of always
by character.
And then as you contract,
it contracts by character.
So you can still select the same
amount, the same granularity
as you could before, but
common selection operations
should be much easier and
more fluid to the user.
In addition to that, you'll
notice the floating palette
there.
Prior to this change
when you selected text,
we would indicate
what you could do,
the actions you could
do with that text
up in the action bar, which
on a phone is not a big deal.
On a tablet is a much
bigger deal, right,
because you may be selecting
text way down here,
and the actions pop up
in a place that's not
even necessarily in your view.
So now we have this floating
action palette instead
that pops up next to the
area that you just indicated
you want to work with.
We also have the ability
to process a text
so you can have an
intent launched when
the user indicates
that they want
to do something with that text.
So you could have, say
a translation service,
that can take the text
that was selected,
and that will be passed
into your intent.
And you can change that
to whatever you want to,
and pass that back to the user.
So check out that API for
more information there.
And we also have a higher
quality text formatting.
This is sort of an
ongoing concern,
how can we make our text
higher quality in general.
One of those ways is by
providing better breaking.
So this means, figuring out
how long all the words are
and then breaking
appropriately so we
don't have this really staggered
thing on the right that
looks rather awkward.
And a big part of that
was enabling hyphenation,
which after having had many
conversations with the text
people in my group, it's
a lot harder problem
than you think it would be.
There's like standard
data where people
expose how to break different
words, and if you think about,
well, you know, I kind of know
how syllables work in English.
I don't know how they work in
other languages, especially
languages that are
maybe left to right
or have a completely different
representation of characters
and ligatures, and
you know, characters
that get built up together
into single characters.
It's very, very complicated.
So we're on our way
to solving that.
There's still some other
internationalization support
that we're working on.
But in the meantime we may
have much higher quality text
breaking in hyphenation
as part of that.
We also have the ability in
static layout to set indent,
so you can set it
to a shaped path.
So you can see here, we've
got the nice round text.
This turns out to be also
a hard problem to solve,
but we've basically just got
a really simple way for you
to say, this is the indents that
I want in this particular area
that I have.
App Linking.
It's possible for you now
when the user selects a link
to launch your
application, and this
happens through a combination
of your application
that's installed on
the device, as well
as your website, your domain
out there because it's
going to be a handshake
between the two of them.
So you have this .json file
that has the information about
the thing that
should be launched,
and certificate information
so that we know, you know,
all the right information is
being shared between the right
parties here.
So we have this asset links
.json with the information
about the app that
should be launched.
And then we've got something
in the manifest on the device
side that says, OK.
Here's the URL
that it refers to.
And we have auto verify
equals true, so this handshake
between the two--
your domain out there,
your device over here.
And then we know,
at install time,
we'll go and look for that
file, look for the information
and know, OK, when the user
goes to that website here's
the application that I'm
going to launch instead.
And then the user can change
this in settings if they want.
Direct Share.
This is the ability
for an application
to share deeper links
within an application,
instead of just the
application itself.
So if you are interacting with
a particular user in a chat
application, maybe
it would make sense
to share information about a
chat with that particular user,
instead of just a chat
application overall.
So you say, well,
here's a chooser service
that I'm going to implement.
So when it needs to it
will launch that chooser
service that you implemented,
and it'll ask you,
are there other targets
that I should choose for you
when they want to go into some,
let's say, the chat target.
And then you can expose
different information there.
So you can say, not just launch
the Hangouts application,
for example, but launch it to
one of these particular users
that they chat with frequently.
We have stylus support.
We always had stylus
support, to some extent.
But it was particular
stylus devices,
it was something that
was plugged in there.
Now we have Bluetooth
stylus support
and we have some new events
that go along with it.
In particular, we
have the button
stylus primary and
button stylus secondary.
Button stylus primary equates
to the button secondary
in earlier releases.
So if you want to track
the same event prior to M,
you can certainly do that.
But if want to track the
stylus event directly in M,
then use the stylus primary.
This is because
the button press,
we still want to track when
the user clicks-- presses
on the screen, we want to
know that that's actually
a touch event, as opposed
to a stylus event.
So that's the primary event
is button press primary
and then button press secondary
is an alias to the button
stylus primary.
And then you can have things
like the click drag gestures,
so they can select
that thing and drag it
on the screen with a stylus.
Let's see.
Graphics.
Let's talk about graphics.
We have something in the camera.
So it used to be that if you
want to turn on the flashlight,
you would grab the camera just
to enable the flashlight, which
seems like a lot of
work to go through
just to light up the closet
when you're in there at night.
So instead, we no
longer require that.
You can actually turn
on the flashlight
without grabbing the
Mutex or the camera
and wasting a lot of
battery in the meantime.
And then there's a simple
API that you can use there.
Alpha optimization.
So.
This gets into some of
the perfmatters stuff
that Colt likes to talk about.
When you are fading out of view,
or setting alpha on a view,
if that view is complicated
it's usually optimal for you
to create a layer for that view.
So that we draw it
once to that layer,
and then we simply
fade that layer.
So, for instance, if you're
running a fading animation,
if you're fading into
view or fading it out,
it would be typical to
use the animated API.
So you'd say,
view.animate.withlayer and that
tells us to build a layer.
And then you animate
alpha to fade it in.
And then you layer gets
torn down when we're done.
We basically do that
for you automatically.
So when we notice
that you're setting
alpha on a layer we will
create, er alpha on a view,
we'll create a layer for you.
And this saves us
from, if you imagine
what the alpha operation
is, the way alpha has
to work is that we have
to draw that view the way
we normally do, so opaquely,
to an external buffer.
And then when we're
done with that thing,
we copy it in translucently.
It's not good enough
for us to draw
all of the individual
operations translucently.
It's a little hard to explain.
I could use a white
board and show you,
but we can't do that, which
means that's the cheap way
to do it and we can't use it.
Instead, we create a buffer,
draw everything, copy it in,
destroy the buffer.
Huge wasted effort on
every single frame.
It's much better to create
the buffer once, use it
for all the frames
that you wanted,
and then tear down the buffer.
So that's what we do.
When we set alpha,
we automatically
create a layer for you, and
then we use that from then on.
It's still better
for you to do it
because you know more about
how that view is being used,
how your animation is being run,
and the timing that you want.
When we first notice
that alpha is non opaque,
that's when we create
the layer, which
means that you may take
a hit on that first frame
as we're going to the effort
of creating the buffer.
So you may rather take that
hit at a different time
when the user is
not going to notice.
So, still use the set layer type
or with layer in View Property
Animator, but if
you don't we'll try
to do the right thing
in the platform.
In the audio area, the
big change was MIDI.
So you can already do
MIDI if you wanted,
but you were kind
of on your own.
Right?
You could receive all the
information through USB
and you could do whatever
you wanted with it.
But now we have classes
and capabilities
that we built for you to
make this a lot easier.
And we also made
it two directional.
So not only do you have
the ability for someone
to play a device into
the Android device
and send in the
note information,
and you know velocity, and
which channel they're playing,
and then you can play
it from your application
if you have some sample,
some sound database,
then you can actually
play those samples based
on the node information that was
coming into the Android device.
But now you also
have the ability
to send the
information out, so you
can have a keyboard
on the Android device,
sending the node
information out, playing
those samples from the
external sample device.
So both sides of
that to check out
MIDI Device Manager and
MIDI Device Service to
know how to interact with those.
In Tools, there's been a
bunch of stuff coming up
to I/O, but also since then.
So, the 1.4 release
came out recently,
and we have the ability
to actually do stuff
with Vector Drawable.
So you can visualize Vector
Drawables in the Tool now,
and you can also take a look
at a lot of standard SVG files
and import those, or export
those, as Vector Drawables.
And I think save those as image
files, as well, so a lot more
flexibility in how you
can deal with vector
art in your application
And also Design
Library Templates.
So there's a lot more
templates in there
that you can use for
standard design patterns that
use some of the design
library components
that I was talking
about earlier.
There's a Theme Editor.
Right now it currently
only handles colors,
but allows you to see
the color palette that's
being used and interact
with that and change that.
GPU and Network Monitors.
These are cool.
There's a lot of
new functionality
that's being integrated
into the tool that
allows you to get the
kinds of information
that Colt likes to talk
about in his videos.
In particular, this gives
you the information,
if you look up at the top one,
that is eerily similar to what
you can already
get on the device
if you enable GPU profile.
You get these colored
bars on the screen
that give you information
about how long
it took us to process
the drawing commands,
how long it took us to send
the information to openGL,
how long it took us to get
the buffer back from openGL.
That information is now
propagated back to the host
and you can see it in real
time in the GPU monitor.
And in the Network
Monitor you can
see how much information is
going in and out of the device
from your application there.
We've got Firebase
integration, for people that
are really into databases, yes?
Yes?
Not me, either.
1.5.
I'm sorry, it's
terribly important.
It's just I'm just
not a data person.
1.5.
This is cool.
Heap dump analysis.
There's been a couple of cool
things about this recently.
It used to be, if you
wanted to find leaks,
important things like activity
leaks, which I may or may not
admit to having introduced
at some points in my past--
ask me some time
about leak hash map.
So, what you would do is
you would take a heap dump.
So there is something in
Android monitor or DDMS where
you can say, take a heap dump.
You'd typically like, GC GC
and then take a heap dump.
And then you would
convert that heap dump,
and then you would run
a tool like MAT which
is a clips standalone or
plugin thing that you can run,
and then you would get
a ton of information
that you would then try
to sort of wade through.
It's like systrace
for memory, right?
You would wade through this
information to figure out,
what existed that
I did not expect,
like seven instances
of my activity.
And then you'd trace it back to
the root set and say, OK why,
did it exist?
Who is referring to this thing
that I thought went away?
Turns out that answer
is a static hash map.
So, instead, there's
a couple of new tools
that are worth mentioning.
One is an external
tool called LeakCanary.
Have people heard of this thing?
Again, we talked to the guy
at square, PY, or Pierryve.
He goes by PY because,
apparently, Americans
can't pronounce his name, who
wrote LeakCanary and its code
that you inject in
your application.
Please don't ship with it.
Use it for your debug version.
I've seen applications ship
with it, and it's ugly.
And it tells you, it
basically monitors
the things that go away, and
if they don't it warns you.
It pops up I think a
toast on the system
and says, oh, by the way, you
just leaked your activity.
That's a great tool.
I would encourage
you to use that.
We also have the ability
now in Android Studio
to do some leak analysis
at a deeper level,
and it has information
specifically about Android,
like activity leaking.
So go ahead and run this.
So this is sort of, it's
more similar to MAT,
sort of the full on,
here's all the information
about references in your system.
But it has information
that's specific to Android,
so it's more focused and
domain specific than MAT is.
Data binding.
There's integration of
fairly straightforward stuff
like syntax highlighting.
So it knows what the language
is that data binding is using.
And [INAUDIBLE] checks,
because there's always
[INAUDIBLE] checks.
Systrace.
We saw a little bit of this
in Colt's keynote earlier.
Very simple UI.
One of my favorites.
It's obvious what's
going on from this trace.
The new thing here, so there's
a couple of new things.
There's events up at the top.
There's a bunch
of little circles
under the green information,
like the second row up there.
And also the-- I wish there
was a laser pointer in here.
I'm going to point
with this anyway.
So the circles right in
the middle of the screen,
where there is, like,
a bunch of red ones
and then a bunch of greens.
Those are basically tips.
So you can click on those now
if you ever looked at systrace
and said, I don't know
what to do with this,
nor do I know the people
that wrote Android,
so I can't do anything
with this information.
Now you can click on
these tips and they're
going to give you a little bit
deeper information about what
we actually saw that
was problematic when
your application was running.
So I clicked on that
tip there, and it said,
list view item recycling
involved inflating views.
Ensure your adapter
get view recycles
the incoming view, instead
of constructing a new one.
I believe this was a trace from
the I/O scheduling application
last year.
And they took the
frame rate down-- up
from horrible to good.
I think just by this.
And you'll find,
actually, if you
use systrace and click on
the tips, a lot of the tips
are the same
because you probably
have the same problem
occurring over and over again.
Moreover, once you fix some
of these fundamental problems,
you'll find a lot of
the overall performance
goes up because
usually there is just
a couple of outlier things,
like running inflation
on the UI thread while
an animation is going.
Or something like this, where
you actually weren't reusing
the view when you should have.
So there is some simple
stuff that we're now
checking for internally.
So I would encourage you
to go back to systrace.
If you gave up because
it was just too hairy,
go back to it now
and see whether it
can help you understand what's
going on with the performance.
And then there's also a
summary panel over on the right
that sort of details all the
different kinds of problems
there were.
And again, there are not usually
an infinite number of problems.
Instead there are probably
an infinite number
of symptoms caused by a
very few number of problems.
So you can sort of see
the tally of what's
going on from what we could
tell from our analysis.
There were improvements
in Art Basic optimization.
This is what the Art team does.
They keep making a run at
it, making things faster.
If you go to the talk that
I'm giving tomorrow morning,
I believe, Android
for Java Developers,
I'm going to talk specifically
about memory concerns there,
and we go into a
fair amount of detail
about how the garbage collector
works both in Dalvik and art.
So there's more information
about some of that side, which
I find kind of interesting.
There's a new API in Art.
You can get some of
the runtime stats.
There's a lot of documentation
in the debug class, where
you can look up information
about all the information you
can get there.
There's some other grab bag
stuff that we wanted to mention
and couldn't really categorize.
You can adopt
external storage now,
so you should avoid
hard coded paths
because, if the user can
adopt a different location
for the data, you
better not depend on it
being where you thought it was.
We give you all the
tools for this already
to be able to query
dynamic paths at runtime.
And that's what you
should use instead.
Also, if you don't
have permanent storage
in your device to actually test
this out with your application,
we would encourage
you to test it anyway
so you can plug-in
a USB drive and then
use the following
A to B command,
to force us to adopt
this rather non
adoptable temporary storage,
just for the purposes
of testing here.
Also, it's important to point
out that Apache HTTP went away.
We deprecate APIs, but we
generally don't remove things
because it's a bit of a
growing pain for developers,
and we don't want to
crash apps out there.
And let's be clear-- we
still didn't actually
remove it from the runtime.
So if you're an old app,
still using Apache HTTP,
it will still run.
It's just that
the API is hidden.
You could not build
against it now.
But I think we said
back in 2011 that people
should stop using this.
And then we finally
hid the API this year.
So it takes a while,
but gal we mean it.
So you should use HTTP
url connection instead.
Boring SSL replaces open SSL.
Who in this room knows what I'm
talking about when I say that?
One, two, three, four.
OK, all right.
I shouldn't have raised
my hand, actually.
I don't really use these APIs.
And
Finally, I would
encourage you to check out
a series of articles that
we published on Medium.com.
This actually came from an
internal effort that we had.
We talked to internal
app developers who said,
we keep talking to
the framework team
and finding out that
we're doing things wrong,
like, we'll ask a question
about how to do something
and the answer will be,
no, don't do it that way.
Or , obviously you should
have used a layer there.
Or, don't do that
on the UI thread.
Or, why are you
churning garbage.
So we have all these
things in our minds,
and the apps teams didn't.
And it turns out
one of the problems
was because a lot
of the internal app
developers at
Google, and probably
like the rest of the world,
came from a world of developing
Java that was quite different.
It is the same
programming language,
but it is not necessarily
the same environment.
If you write Java
programs for a server,
and then you try to use those
same patterns and approaches
to write a mobile application,
you will suffer for it, right?
Because we do not have the
same kind of constraints
on mobile devices.
We don't have the
same resources,
we don't have the same memory.
It's not the same runtime.
There's a lot of things that
are very, very different, apart
from the programming
language itself.
So we wrote this
extremely long article
that we posted
internally and said, OK,
here's all the information
from the platform
team about all this stuff that
we've built up over the years.
The things that
you should avoid.
The patterns that you
should use on Android.
And then we went to
publish it externally,
and it wouldn't fit anywhere,
because it was just too long.
So we split it into
ten different articles
that are posted on Medium.
Each one of those 10 articles
are not in themselves short.
The introduction is,
because it doesn't
have any information in it.
Everything, else fairly long.
Please check it out.
Go to medium.com.
There's a Google Developers
publication there,
or it's published under
by writing name there.
It's all information
that I think all Android
developers should understand.
It's a little bit hard to
write rules for Android,
like it is patterns for software
development, like always
do this.
For example, just to pick
a particularly painful one
out there, there's a rule in
there saying, avoid Enums.
OK.
That tends to be a
trigger for some people.
But that, like all of
the rules in the document
are, depending on
your situation.
What you need to do is
understand why they can be bad.
If you're writing
a library and you
have Enums scattered
within them,
that may be bad
for all the users
that are using their
library because they're all
going to take the memory
hit of that approach.
If there's a cheaper way to
do what you wanted to do.
If you use an Enum
in your application,
I personally don't care.
I don't think it's
affecting anything.
But, you should understand
when it can have impact.
And you should understand the
other things in those articles,
as well.
They don't-- not all of the
rules apply to all developers,
but it's kind of good to get
a sense for what the problems
are, as well as why.
And then also come to the
talk tomorrow, if you can.
There may be other interesting
talks on at the same time.
Though, Android
for Java Developers
is basically going over
some of those rules,
specifically in memory.
I only have an hour, so
it's about a three hour talk
where I had to do everything.
So we'll just spend
an hour talking
about some of the memory
concerns tomorrow morning.
So, I would say go check out
information about Marshmallow.
Here's a couple of
URLs to look at.
And here's us, or me.
And that's it.
Thank you.
[MUSIC]